today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
hitter man you know is ah dude can you
believe snails exist think about that
think about being a snail slow as hell I
mean what's the most you travel probably
in and you're in your whole life
not that far think about that hey what
if another snail send you a letter so
I'm like hey you should come see us out
in Nevada or something dude it would
take you seven generations of offspring
to get for your family to get to Nevada
if you're a damn snail think how would
you even snail that is a one of mother
nature's really limited time offers I
feel like butt
[Music]
celebrate live
celebrate
[Music]
we celebrate days
[Applause]
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die Oh
D and that is Spencer Jacob growl with
celebrate in a beautiful song and and it
is July 1 in the year 2019 2019 and we
are in July 1 and welcome to this past
weekend and thanks for for stopping by
and it's celebrate that's that song
right there by Spencer Jacob growl and
and and it's a great week to celebrate
it's that week it's that baby
it's that blown up baby that that fourth
of July and this the time when [ __ ] gets
really turned out just that Betsy Ross
you know fourth of July is a special
time of year this the time of year when
you would see you know you know
Alexander Graham would maybe uh you know
let a couple ladies come ring his bell
you feel me
this one Betsy Ross would maybe showed
him show them front heaters boy show
them you know you know she would flash
you know she'd lift up that flag and
flash those milk nodules at the
neighbors it is the fourth of July it's
when you get as American as you a
marijuana two and you get to do what you
do you know maybe put a little put a
special sauce on a frank and just hum
that thing at the neighbor you know
maybe you play go deep and that's where
you have somebody run down a street and
you throw a hot dog as far as you can
and see if they can catch it in their
mouth and that's a beautiful thing it's
an old
that's an old Pride Month trick as well
but it is time to celebrate is to
celebrate America a lot to celebrate
here fourth of July on the docket fourth
of July the year it mean we are halfway
over your do it uh it's halfway maybe
you know halfway is a big point really
you know if you think about something
like if you got a big sandwich you know
you got what you need you know you got
that meaty treat that freakin Lincoln
log that's got you thinking about you
know maybe some muster to relish and boy
I'm a relish you know I love relish
sometime when you know when you're
thinking about hot dogs and this and
that you see people they get they doing
mustard you see somebody doing mustard
in armor when I was young I would see a
man pick up that mustard bottle and just
really I mean just control that thing is
he just sprayed it on that Frank I mean
some man he just I remember seeing this
one man and he would you he picked up
that mustard and just turned it right
over with the nozzle down just like he
had done some like he's do spray
caulking or something for a contractor
you know this guy I mean he and he just
filled in that Frank with that mustard
and hit it straight into his jowls
whoo-hoo and he just he answered that
question boy and put that that meat al
right into his jowls baby that big Frank
and what I like is you know is relish
though there's always that odd jar of
that condiment that odd condiment that's
sitting off to the side that green some
people don't even know what relish is
some people see a thing a relish or like
damn what is it looks like a salad maybe
had a heart attack or got electrocuted
and that's relish and relishes you know
it's everything kind of it's almost like
it's like being in love when you're
young it's romantic and it's sweet and
it's spicy and relishes like kind of
soft and it's wet but it's you know
trying to hold itself together and it it
doesn't know what it is sometimes is it
a vegetable is it uh is it a sauce is it
a you know what is it and you can see
relish sometimes you can almost envision
the bottle or the little jar you know
relish comes in a little jar a little
glass cage really and you can almost if
you think about relish you could see it
just one you could see it may be at a
therapists office sitting on accounts
just kind of wondering what it is
because the other condiments the other
they're very clear it's ketchup you know
this is tomatoes and this is a a
specific sauce and that must hard boy
you hit that you know you see a man a
strong man to heart but then you got
relish it's got a spoon out of it
sometimes coming out the jar the lid is
missing like where's the lid who-who
gonna you know how they gonna contain
this relish if they need to yeah and
that's why I think you know I've always
related to relish I've always related to
relish because I never knew kind of some
what I am or but I'm right off there you
know I see the ketchup stare the
mustards there and they're partying and
sometimes they you know people love them
in there
but then I'm there too I don't know what
I don't know what I am sometimes but I'm
trying to hang in there
you know I'm independent I'm by Minda
I'm on the party table you know I'm
there with the other you know I'm right
next to the beef franks and on the pad
he's in the turkey patties
but I'm independent at the same time so
yeah I think I've always related to
relish and it's Independence Day coming
up it's Independence Day so if you you
know if you feeling alone man this is
your day hey man independent as you want
to be you know and I think a lot about
independence I think you know a lot of
people ask me about like oh you know do
you when you're gonna do a Netflix
special when you're gonna do this when
are you gonna do a special and I think
about that but I think about you know I
mean there's been offers for a special
for a stand-up comedy special but I
think about this what if you sell a
special to a platform you know in a
platform that's like Netflix or Amazon
or you know Comedy Central a different
place if one day they decide they don't
like your voice being in the world which
sounds maybe they wouldn't people say
well maybe they wouldn't do that or it
might not
well if one day they do if you sell them
something
then this there's they own it so they
could press a button and you off your
off the docket
you know you your your your your voice
doesn't even exist anymore and when I
see sometimes you know a lot of times I
mean they haven't even put you know I
feel like if some of these places I
haven't even put somebody from you know
like a rural person on television in or
on you know giving them some
opportunities in a long time so it makes
me think well what if they just decide
oh we don't like this this guy's voice
anymore then week they can eliminate it
if they own it so I just think about
that you know I think about that well
once I
something to them they own it and they
could delete it when they want to and
that I won't exist you know so it's it's
just a battle sometimes to think well do
I just want to stay independent and just
this way I know that no matter what you
you know right or wrong no matter what
choices I make or decisions I make even
if some of them are ok and some were not
okay someone else doesn't get to say oh
well we didn't like this choice this
person made in their life or this thing
they did and we don't like their voice
being out there and we can take them off
of our platform and since we own their
voice since we own what they sold us
then the mess that they're gone and some
of you might say well that's kind of
crazy to think about but I don't know if
it is I mean it seems like people's
voices can get muted a lot of times
these days if they're owned by someone
else so I just you know I think about
independence I think about you know I
mean America was founded people wanted
to be independent I mean things you know
things was going so bad in Britain some
people got into a boat and left and the
people in Britain were like where are
you going and they're like we don't know
I mean that's crazy things must have
been really rocky if you left and didn't
even know where you were going and only
had just a couple sandwiches a couple of
you know decent chicks which II didn't
even have something eating having real
you know amazing batch you know a couple
cauldrons of soup or whatever gunpowder
that gunpowder chowder but that's what
they were eating back then
I mean you needed something you could
you know you could pop off and then
something you could fill your gullet and
something that you could you know that
you could fill your musket you that
gunpowder chat or something that you
know you needed that that that
double-edge meal you know that way you
could use it to fight you can use it to
feast but
crazy independence you know so yeah
people ask about that about being
independent and what I think about it
and about doing a special and that's one
of the things that kind of holds me up
sometimes it's just some thing where I
don't want to be owned by someone I
don't want someone to own me where one
day they could say well we don't really
want your voice out there so you know we
don't like your kind I mean I feel
enough of that when I even got out here
to Hollywood we don't you know oh you
sound this way you're not really well
you know I just you know it's kind of
life a sour taste in my mouth oh you
don't have I don't know man
you know they think everybody where I'm
from is a just a racist or a an idiot
you know they think a lot of rural white
people or rural people at all or just
the ignorant you know and it just I
don't know man I've never really felt
super welcome and now some of that could
be my own fault maybe sometimes I don't
want to be welcome you know maybe
there's something inside of me that that
would that that doesn't want to be
welcomed I mean maybe I'm people could
lay out a hundred welcome mats and maybe
I wouldn't notice it but I do notice
when people's voices get silenced if
they're not a certain way and I don't
think my voice is that but who knows in
ten years from now if that's what people
if you know somebody has some companies
like man this this guy doesn't think
like other ways same exact way I think
about everything so we got to get it you
know let's take them off the platform
and then you're going so I don't know I
just think about that kind of stuff
sometimes you know you work so hard to
create your own voice to just try and
stay independent and just do your own
thing and then something comes along and
you know I don't know it's like the
snail man I mean you don't even know
that snail doesn't even know he he'll
trudge his whole life to get 40 feet
but then his son you know his son he
might have a little bit at 39 feet he
might you know slug up with another
little bedbug and then they got didn't
they have a baby and that baby goes you
know the next generation he goes that
next 40 feet and then the next
generation goes the next 40 feet and
they just keep going you know sometimes
it takes a couple of legs to get
somewhere it takes a couple of
generations to get somewhere
you know if you riding that independence
you got a really sometimes you got to
ride it out
so anyway I'm not saying that I wouldn't
do a comedy special with another group
or something like that but I really you
know I would tough time thinking about
being about my artwork and stuff being
owned by somebody or my stories I mean
and maybe I'm overthinking things that's
fine but you know I can't help the way
that I think you know all the times the
way that I think this is just you know
I'm kind of sentenced kind of stuck here
in this I mean some people's brain this
really makes perfect sense you got that
cucumber you got them them Tomatis boy
but then damn boy I got this I got this
jar relish up here I had a great time
hitting a hitting Oklahoma in Texas I
want to thank everybody that came out of
San Antonio in San Antonio I don't have
you ever been here they got a lot of you
know downtown they had a lot of real
vagrants chillin like a lot of
hitchhikers but nobody none of them are
hiking they're just hitch and they're
just literally just hitched right there
I mean there's no you know a lot of
people that look like you're about to
catch the bus but never get on the bus
you feel me it's kind of like a little
kind of like a really it's like kind of
like a Southwestern Sacramento in a way
are like a southern Sacramento had that
same vibe but amazing krile that came
out man beautiful people beautiful
people man
and just a man I went in with in the
lobby they had out of the hotel that we
stayed at they had horchata and horchata
boy if you never had this stuff it's
basically dude if I come back
reincarnated I hope I come back
reincarnated as a little Latino you know
as a little McDonald because I want that
sweet sweet that sweet sweet breast milk
and I want that sweet tits if that dude
that let you to hang bra that horchata
dude and you know if your mom's serving
up or chowder bro you gonna you
definitely probably gonna be able to
dance cuz you're gonna have [ __ ]
sugar in your step mmm
but they had a little jug of it in the
lobby at a hotel you get you a little
ladle and ladle you out a sip of that
[ __ ] a sugary that sugary Mexican
salsa bron it was good dude uh yeah I
can't even I mean who knew breast milk
sign me up
we have some calls that came in man and
let's get to a couple of calls on the
hotline of him I got to go get a
cortisone shot or something my neck is
killing me so let me get into this call
the hotline as always is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three here
we go that [ __ ] was nice I was at your
9:30 show in Austin
oh yeah gang brother thank you for
coming out thank you for coming out that
was a beautiful theater air in Austin a
beautiful theater man I mean that kind
of place you could damn shoot the
president in beautiful they had I mean I
don't even know and they had a bowl of
all those circus peanuts backstage you
hon I am i probably had 40 of them dude
I probably had 40 of them bro I got
Barnum and Bailey in my bowels brah
really I had about 40 of those little
those beautiful kind of pink
circus peanuts and they're kind of sweet
but also kind of good and they're not
even really peanuts actually so anybody
could eat them on a airplane without
dying you know so that's beautiful but
let's go on onward it was an amazing
show by the way I had no idea you were
so animated the whole show we fought the
back with me oh thanks man
that's nice you to say it dude you know
I ah the second show in Austin was was
really good the first one I was feeling
a little bit I had a lot on my mind but
that second one did I really felt that
fire but afterwards man that was a
commotion I don't know how it usually
goes this show but that [ __ ] was nuts
dude I was standing in this crowd and
you know everyone's trying to get your
picture taken with you and I was
standing there and I was I was doing the
same thing and now I got to admit it it
felt a little dirty
I just because we were all just kind of
getting a little rowdy it was kind of
crazy and at one point I heard someone
say I touched his mullet you know yeah I
thought that was a little crazy and
that's a pervert usually more crazy but
anyway I wasn't able to get in there and
get a picture with you but that's all
good man hi hey gang bro well thank you
for calling and thanks for coming out
man
you know yeah you know after the show
sometimes like I feel bad because I
don't get to meet a lot of people that
come to the shows you know we've been
doing meet-and-greets at some of the
shows and because otherwise you at some
point you just you would be there all
night and it's it's it just gets exalt
it really does get exhausting it's
awesome but it just gets you know it
just gets off I've just been you know
I've just been tired I've been trying to
eliminate some stress and stay less
stressed and the biggest thing I want to
be able to do is perform well for
everybody or perform well for anybody
that comes out so yes so we had you know
so after the show sometimes if there's
no if
there's not even a meet-and-greet or
anything I'll try and just sneak out and
just you know buzz out and get some pics
with people or say hey or see what's
going on and you know cuz I like to know
who's coming to the show and who just
who you are you know I feel so bad
sometimes that I do so much talking and
and I don't get to know a lot of times
who you are so so I try to pop out and
meet some people and yeah in Austin it
was a it was a little while a lot of
people wanted to get photos and and and
I'm okay with it the the you know the
part because most of the people were
just super nice you know most of them
are super nice though hey man uh me and
my brother came my wife and I came or
you know you'll see a guy I'm so proud
man I brought my dad out he you know
he's never been to a comedy show and or
we never been to a comedy show together
you know you'll see somebody hey man you
know we have our first baby coming up
and you know we love listening to you
somebody will be like oh we put you on
when we fall asleep at night and I'm
like dang dang that's kind of but it's
also sweet of you and so you know it's
just whoo it's nice to just see what
people you know what would you would
your thinking with what I'm thinking and
what you're thinking and being able to
match those vibes a little but yeah
outside in the Austin it got it was
though it was a lot of people and it was
and I just felt bad because you know I
just wanted to get to say hit everybody
and I tried to do you know state do as
many as I could the venue got pissed off
and they you know the lady in there got
all rambunctious saying liability and
insurance issues and stuff and dude
whatever you know if I thought we spent
my whole life thinking about that kind
of stuff then I'm not really gonna be a
little much of a life Emma but thank you
for coming out man and thanks for the
call I appreciate it and yeah you know I
guess they're you know I think about
that sometimes like you're getting a
picture with someone is it dirty and I
think I can you I usually try and be
able to tell like if somebody's being
mean if they're white you know sometimes
I'll have a guy come up and his wife
will be drunk and she'll be saying roots
I don't need a I don't need a photo with
you I don't need us to really share that
much of a moment of our lives if you
guys are you know if people are being
mean or something but sometimes you know
it's uh it's people but just being nice
or being chill and so it's like you know
sometimes it's nice to be able to just
capture a moment capture a smile you
know I try to put a big smile in there I
used to be afraid to smile a lot of
times you know when so much my life even
a lot of my 20s I was just afraid to
smile I just hated the way that my smile
looked and so I was afraid to do it but
but yes it definitely feels like it can
get a little meat-market e in there you
know somebody will put a little somebody
put a couple of uh smoked almonds in my
pocket so I don't know if that's an old
religious thing or something but some
lady or man hit about four or five
smoked almonds in my pocket I brought
them back home with me I got them on the
kitchen counter right now so I don't
know what that's for
but I'm have to look it up but you know
in Chinese culture they say that they
used to say that taking a photo with
someone they didn't want to do it
because it took a part of your soul let
me look that up Chinese don't take
pictures because let me see what this do
culturally that photography can steal
your soul yes a number of cultures do
not want their spirits captured by a box
while most now accept that this will not
occur when photography was first around
it was magical in a way that made people
fear it I remember being a student and
being studying abroad or just traveling
and going to China for a couple of days
or Hongkong and they had a woman there
with her granddaughter and they were
just they were so unique to me looking
to me and and they just had like we're
having a fun cute exchange and so I went
and got my camera to take a photo of him
and they stopped me the woman came up
and stopped me
and they didn't want it they said it
could believe that it could take part of
your soul you know but well here's
another one it says the belief in a soul
or spiritual double of a person is found
in almost every culture in the world
even Western peoples have some belief in
things affecting images of a person it
will affect them
oh so that's almost like voodoo dahling
you know that the people if you know I
mean it's almost the same thing people
will believe that if you had an image of
someone that you could then conjure
spells on upon that image or upon that
doll that's kind of interesting people
there was also beliefs your images in
the mirror if you break the mirror it
affects you that could have been where
that seven years of bad luck comes from
you know if you break a mirror what else
but yeah there's the you know there's an
old belief that yeah you get photos and
it takes part of your soul but but yeah
I don't think we're doing any soul
taking but I hope if I see you again and
you want to grab a snap man we'll get it
you know it's funny and half the people
outside of there half of them come up
for any want to say it get a photo half
of the people I just want to say hey so
it's kind of just a mix really but but
just excited to be able to put on a good
show man I'm glad that you enjoyed it I
appreciate you all peeping it breath
what else we got we got a call that came
in here ninety five six six four nine
five zero three is the hotline here we
go what's up Evan thank you for calling
Bron we tried to go to Barton Springs
and get in the river and he said it was
closed for painting or something and
that shook my dude that shook the
freakin bait right out of my Dayne out
of my bass mouth you feel me because how
you painting if you're a river if you're
a park you know a river
Riverpark so i guess i just caught on
now I wanted to thank you man for being
so open you know honest and really
vulnerable about some of the things you
bring up I've been listening for like
about a year now dude thanks for
listening man I don't even know what the
hell I'm doing sometimes Soho and by
sometimes I mean most of the time I mean
today do you don't even want to start
this episode I just felt nervous and I
just felt kind of scared but and that's
why I was even thinking about snails at
the beginning of this episode because
snails dude how much how much scared
must they be know when they slow as hell
or no one is gonna take forever it must
be scary to just start scooting you only
have it wheels you'd think if a snail at
least had a secret wheel inside of him
he would enjoy it but they don't even
have it any secret wheels you know when
you started saying that you have no
problem with porn and you're trying to
get that out of your life
I started thinking like you can do that
I guess something I struggle with but I
didn't I didn't put it together that
it's something I can actually maybe work
on you know you know people talk about
their problems with form but in a joking
way they never stay like you know it's
something I'm actually trying to find a
work on a funny thing is I I just got a
vasectomy a few weeks back and dang boy
and that sounds like the dark arts boy
letting somebody inside of your nuts
with some scissors dude I didn't know
when you get a vasectomy the doctor said
I got a bust like 40 nuts in like two
months
what dude this sounds like a really a
bad chapter of the Bible that doesn't
exist you got a bus 40 nuts in two
months dude bro you that's a lot there
you gonna be like D are like the Michael
Phelps of really busboy dude you're
gonna need a pool you're gonna be
swimming in your own seed brother this
sounds really unconventional that's
pretty doable when you got a toddler at
home no full-time job
dude if you busting 40 nuts dog ain't
gonna have a full-time job you're gonna
be on a gurney buddy if you're doing 40
nuts out of yourself you're gonna be on
a gurney it's a feat so I'm trying to
juggle that while doing this
masturbation Olympics over here it shows
you you know it's just it's just one of
those things it's like you don't realize
that you can stick something about
yourself sometimes until you see someone
else doing it to themselves no so thank
you for that and and yeah that's all man
thank you you're welcome man a sweetie
to say that you know I'm really I never
really plan on like you know thinking
that I would be like influencing anybody
too you know we're not influencing but
just thank you brother sweetie to say
you know I uh waters don't want somebody
if look man I hate it dude I hate it so
much of my 20s brah I spent you know I
was uncomfortable around women a lot of
times I would get very nervous sexually
and so then at a certain point I would
just watch pornography and masturbate at
the house and do that jerk out you know
and I used to hate jerking off indoors
because I felt like it was real sinful
you know so I would jerk off outdoors
you know nature back in the nature and
just you know show that work to the Lord
out there but but then after a while you
know I was masturbating indoors and I
mean things were just getting out of
control and and then was pornography
really popped off I mean it was just
dude I would have a date set up with a
girl that I liked and then I would end
up masturbating and then I would cancel
the date and sit at home and have maybe
a 40 or 60 count of vanilla creams and
that was it and I would do that and that
just started to grow on itself to where
I was just mostly what I was I was
basically a masturbator that also had a
job like you know but a full-time master
but guy and I wasn't masturbating like
ten times a day or anything was just
once a day
usually but it would be like his bad
habit it was like I finished my day
watch pornography and then I didn't
really get in any trying be in any
relationships or or even communicate
with women that much because I didn't
really need to you know I still had some
desires but the biggest thing I knew out
I was finishing off I was polishing
myself you know I was gonna give myself
that fast hand snail you feel me so but
but then you know a couple years ago I
realized it was a problem for me and
then about a year ago I realized man I
can put on different blockers on my
computer and phone and no joke I feel so
much better now it's been a year now
since I put blockers on my computer and
phone and I think only twice have I
looked at pornography in the past year
maybe three times that blows my mind
because I never thought that would be
the case and it affected my relationship
with women I didn't want it you know I
still have you know like I would still
get to you know catch a little bit of
trim here you know or catch this you
know hunt a little bit of you know that
moisture out there you know I'd be out
there hunting that you know that soft
little leg trout you feel me but but but
I wasn't feeling let me see
not watching pornography makes me I'm
just a little bit mourning actually
engaged towards went towards females
like I have it just I don't know I like
I'm just my confidence is a little more
my actual desire to communicate and
interact on a human level because my
brain isn't distorted anymore about just
this this just only sexual idea and so
you know it's given me a new opportunity
to see women and more of a complete
light and more a little more
multifaceted to the point where then I
can care about them more because before
pornography had really kind of
charge some of my growth in that area
all right it halted it and now I feel a
little bit more open just like - I don't
know just ideas that I wasn't open to
before you know I care a little bit more
about and it's giving me more confidence
my self-confidence has gotten better
since I quit masturbating and my shame
has really justed and I was after a
while I was so ashamed to myself and I
didn't realize it
masturbation makes me feel shameful and
and I think it's okay that it does dude
you have the gift of the of the you have
the ability to create life and you
busting it out into a dang you know into
a firm or a bougainvillea or whatever
the yard or a sink or something or a
little you know my buddy used to jerk
off into a Country Crock thing an empty
one you know but still so so yeah I
don't have that shame it you know I
still I just don't have as much shame as
I used to in that it's been priceless
bro but thank you for calling and saying
that you know that you sure that you've
you know recognized that maybe that's
something in your life that is something
that could be adjusted because yeah how
can I love a woman really or have even a
lot more feelings like that if I if the
only way I see them a lot of times is in
is these intense sexual ways through
pornography and look I'm not saying
something you know there's some sultry
stuff out there you know I remember you
show you know you show me a leg you know
a nice [ __ ] that thick thigh hanging
out of a damn Corvette window and I'm
you know I'll chub up a little now and I
get more natural and rural chubs than I
used to I used to chub I used to only
get chubs
you know only during um watching
pornography but now I'll get some body
each other I mean I'm in an elevator on
an airplane so but thanks for calling
man and uh and that's nice of you dude
good luck with the family of it air
and I don't know if you got to do 40 in
on whatever you were doing a month or
whatever that's you might want to reread
exodus or whatever CH I don't know what
chapter you got that out it but you
might want to peek around on that I also
want to say this man we had a young
fella who was a fan of the podcast
Tyler is his name and and he passed away
and his mother came out and saw me in
Austin and brought me a picture of him
and it will have it on the YouTube right
now and I had met him in Addison and and
I remember meeting him and he was a
sweet fella a nice guy big smile and
just he had so much good come joy coming
out of him
you know you could tell it's not
surprising you know God had really put
his him on fast-forward because he I
mean he just it almost seemed
astronomical i how is the kid was you
know and now i see that you know that
you know he would just they were
expediting the joy out of them because
they was they were bringing him back on
to the other side and yeah it wasn't
anything tragic you know he passed away
in his sleep but his mother came out to
a show in Austin and brought me a
picture of me and him from when I met
him in Addison and I was very sweet and
I really appreciate that and you know
you know and I'm sorry for their loss
you know I can't imagine what that's
like and I'm grateful that I got to meet
your your boy even for just a minute and
I hope to I hope you know that some of
the energy that I met whenever I met him
I hope it stays alive inside of me and I
appreciate you for bringing me that
picture of him and him and me that's
really sweet of you let's take another
couple calls here we go
hey yo this is Chandler representing
Nashville I'll be on the North Shore
next week you'll see above then I got a
question
what's up Chandler thank you for hitting
me up man thanks for calling in onward
can you seen some shift man I I grew up
I saw something I don't have you seen
this man we were the on the soccer team
man there was assistant coach he he
talked about the marble game it was his
game and he got us all hooked on it
where you put a marble in somebody's
bellybutton and it was how quick could
you get that out there with your tongue
man have you seen that have you seen the
marble game bro
just want to see your thoughts on that
anything similar Gang Gang brother well
if you glue it in there I mean I think
if you superglue a marble in your
bellybutton and then you do it you're
gonna have it's gonna be a fun or game
probably it's gonna well that's super
cool and your skin is gonna burn
but it's gonna be more of a heated
competition I think just trying to get a
marble out of somebody it wouldn't be
that crazy you know we had this thing
they would put I don't know if I'm gonna
it might not be this day to talk about
that one but you know people do like
kind of a hold of marble in their finked
her and try to just you know hold on
through a couple of songs it would play
different songs and stuff on the guitar
and you can see if you could hold it um
but thank you for calling man a lot of
unique games out there you should do
sugar mouth and uh and people would put
sugar in their mouths and fill it and
you try to slap it out of each other's
faces but that was when you were young
and you could really bounce back pretty
quick um what else man let's take
another call that came in here here we
go
hey Jersey I'm talking about your
parents sleeping it off thank you for
calling Steve a New Jersey beautiful
place man probably one of the top 50
places in America I think homework I
think you know question of my
relationship because my wife and I you
know a lot of times we sleep in
different beds and you know we do love
each other there's a lot you know
while of our relationship I think the
most party's walk-off hit shift and it
led to a lot of fights just being up
rolling around while she's trying to go
to sleep so we kind of have an agreement
for sweeping different sentence I don't
want people to know it might not be a
bad thing like you can still love each
other and get good sleep in different
bed um we have a kid on the way actually
and congratulations man that's amazing
that's awesome man congratulations boy
so will it wonder how that'll affect the
the bet the you know the Romeo and
Juliet kind of sleeping style the the
tag aways and the Montagues or whatever
what does it tag aways no I don't know
onward
you know I can't believe I'm going to be
a father for the first time but it I
mean I'm getting choked up even saying
it but uh I just hope my kid understand
that I love my wife and if we aren't
sleeping the different residence on this
they know we love each other and it
doesn't matter we're just trying to get
some sleep
hey man I've been a listener distance'
one I appreciate everything you do yeah
yeah Gang Gang bro thank you for uh you
know that's so funny you said that yeah
it's like you just you hope your kid
knows that you and your wife love each
other
you know it's funny it's like you know
it's so funny how we can all it's hard
to let people like time is so weird cuz
it's so it's so hard to let people know
what we want them to know at certain
times kind of you know like when I was a
kid I wanted all ah just one of my mom
just to be okay you know I wanted her to
feel okay I wanted her to not have to
work and not have to stress out and I
just wanted to help her and I wanted to
her to know that I that I wanted to help
so much and I couldn't express it as a
kid I was just too young I didn't know
how to do it I just you know and here
you are you know you guys are about to
have a kid and you want the kid to know
that you and your wife love each other
you wanted the kid to know how much you
that you already love it even though
it's not even here you know
you and the kid that the your child
won't even be able to really don't feel
that I'm sure but that you won't be able
to tell them that until in a way that
they can accept it and know and really
hear it maybe till their 20s even you
know when a when someone can really
understand what someone else's feelings
aren't stuff you know I mean you'll be
able to tell them as they're growing up
I love you and this and that but later
when they get a little older they might
really be like wow you know this my
parents really cared for me this whole
time and but you want them to know that
now and that's so so normal I mean it's
it's just so interesting how you know we
we would it's like our at the time it's
like what we want to have what sometimes
it's so hard that we can't express we
can never fully Express and when we're
trying to say here I mean I know what
I'm trying to say that sometimes it's
interesting we can never really express
to somebody how much they that we care
or how much we want them to know they
are loved you know and we can never do
it in real time sometimes it's hard it's
like I don't know I mean I know what I'm
saying but I just can't iterate it
exactly but that really hit me man yeah
you just want her to know that you and
your wife love each other and I think
that there's no doubt there's no doubt
that your kid's gonna know that I mean
if you guys were sleeping on opposite
ends of the world I feel like your kid
might know it that's cool though dude
what are you woody would a big adventure
and yeah I think it's a loving thing to
sleep on other side of the size of the
nest man so you guys can get a little
bit of rest especially if you're working
odds and ends but yeah I think even just
having you even just having like you
know you could always play that message
for your daughter and see or your son
and say look you know this is how much I
loved you before you were even born you
I remember a couple years ago about five
years ago into this thing it was called
landmark and it was like this it's a
thing that people go to to learn about
thoughts in their past and this and that
and and I remember that one of the lunch
breaks they tell you to go call someone
in your life and I remember call him on
Mohammed just saying you know Mom did
you love me when I was a kid you know
because I just needed to know I'd never
asked her and I'd never known and I
didn't have any more thoughts in my head
that when I was a kid you know I didn't
want to be just have I didn't wanna have
errant thoughts where I didn't think
that my mother loved me when I was a kid
even if she couldn't relate to me or
whatever I just didn't want to think
that she couldn't that she didn't love
me and so she said yes she said you know
I always loved you I've always loved you
and it was it was something I needed to
hear I didn't realize it you know and it
was scary to even ask her you know I was
like walking around I was pacing outside
of this conference room
you know crying on this [ __ ] body's
damn they had a dama not beat what a
damn thing a wasp's or whatever and
[ __ ] this people's eatin lunch and
doing sandwiches and I'm out there like
did you love me you know me [ __ ] damn
Muppet but but I needed to know you know
I needed to know because it was a part
of me inside of me that just wanted that
just it was more of a question mark than
it was uh you know a caulking you know
it wasn't really filled in you know I
needed that you know I just needed it to
be filled in all right I'm gonna take a
second and just support an artist that
has helped out this podcast and and just
um I mean this guy has made a drawing
and this guy is Joe ace and he's an art
connoisseur and he's made a drawing a
beautiful sketch of every guest that we
have had on the episode and I mean these
cards that he's done are absolutely
remarkable
Joe AC is an art connoisseur he is a
maker of stuff
he's made art for our studio and and
custom portraits of all of our guests
like I said I mean we have all of them
you know I don't know if you know if you
can see I'm right here we've got Chris
Hansen Bert Kreischer the sex lady
therapist who was in the glasses
we got Sebastian Maniscalco stun them
all Ron White and he's not even trying
to sell stuff you know he what he wants
to build as a community of cool people
who like art so if you want to do him
the favor of following his work on
Instagram at Ace a cej underscore and
that's AC e dot the letter j and then
underscore for future contests giveaways
and available art he also he didn't
cease not selling anything he did this
totally out of the the good will of his
own heart heart art and what we have
thought about if we could get permission
to make a deck of cards and and have the
money go towards maybe single moms or
some charity or do something special we
had two single moms that so thank you so
much Joe ace I want to thank you very
much man I can't it blows me away when I
look through this deck of cards are this
deck of portraits it I mean it
absolutely blows me away just everybody
we've even had on here man we had two
single moms that came out in in Tulsa
and I just want to thank you guys for
your support and we're gonna follow up
with them this week and and one of them
was one of the same single mothers that
had come out in in West Siloam Springs
over about a year ago the first one that
ever came out Julie Swenson and so we
got to see her again and her son is ten
years old now he just celebrated his
10th birthday and and they seem to be
just doing great and we're gonna follow
up with them this week and do something
special for them to help out with the
kiddos this summer and he
and thank you very much tpw all the
listeners and supporters you know and
you know that's what we do here it's
what we try to do anyway and sometimes
we fail and sometimes we don't today's
episode is brought to you by skills
share skills share it's an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes in design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career may be either
something you can't do you can't do a
recipe or make a um you know like a
booyah base or something a romantic soup
but if you get on Skillshare you may be
able to solve that in ability you can
take classes in social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain a professional skill
skills share is there to keep you
learning thriving and reaching those new
goals you want to learn filmmaking try
low-budget filmmaking tips and tricks
for an indie look one of the most
popular courses on Skillshare join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free just go
to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von to start your two months now
that Skillshare com
slash Theo von right now I want to call
in actually I'm gonna call there's a lot
of you guys follow barstool or know
about them one of their writers who I
performed with him Boston Francis Ellis
just got let go by them and I want to
give him a call right now to find
a little bit more about what happened
because it's really interesting to me
big Francis I'm doing good man you sound
unemployed I do no you don't man you
sound good I'm just joking I feel good I
feel good I don't know I don't feel
unemployed but I am well you just kind
of I guess kind of do you feel set free
like what kind of happened with the
situation it seemed well what happened
with the situation sure on Friday
I wrote a blog about a girl who was
missing for a week the headline that I
saw was that her sorority sisters had
seen her Instagram was active so there
was reason to hope and then I read a
headline that said that the authorities
didn't suspect foul play I thought that
meant she was kind of okay in my mind
that men good news yeah yeah and I
didn't even really think about what was
actually happening and if you read the
blog I wrote I wasn't making fun of her
I was kind of just lazily these things
you know here's the story she's also a
fan of a podcast we have a barstool
hopefully though you know when she turns
up okay those girls can send her some
merchandise yeah yeah checked it out
yeah and you know I think that the tone
and the timing were what really made it
so so bad and so careless and and just a
major oversight on my part and very
thoughtless and it came off kind of
heartless and they had to let me go and
I totally understand their decision so
mm-hmm
yeah I mean III I've been following that
case pretty close like mean as much as I
could just in the news you know checking
up a couple times a day and seeing what
was going on yeah I guess I guess like
you said the timing and the tone but
don't you think like do you feel that
like Anna
I mean it's like obviously if I listen
to you right now talking about it it's
very obvious like what happened like you
you know you misjudged what was going on
you fat you know you were taking things
from the news stories and yeah you
weren't mean you weren't malicious and
you just kind of made I guess kind of an
accident I did I think you know it's
very important to note that what what my
intention was which was not to somehow
disgrace the memory of a girl who had
lost her life
yeah of course not was it was just sort
of I guess highlight a major news story
that I thought was developing in a
different way and my my big fault was
that I should have been I should have
read more about it and realized that
regardless of what the outcome was this
was still a situation I should not have
touched upon and of course a couple
hours after I wrote it they've been they
announced that they had found a suspect
and then it started really looking hard
you know horrible from there yeah and
that's when I took the blog down and I
was I realized my how just awful my
mistake had been so yeah do you think
like but do you think that most people
are like understanding in and can can
forgive you like I mean most people yeah
like I even when I read it I was like oh
man Frances just sitting kind of
realized what was going on this was a
mistake but you know it's things happen
and and that's and that's that yeah I
think I was actually kind of made I was
I was encouraged by the response to my
mistake because I thought I have we live
in this world where there's a lot of
outrage and you know people equate a lot
of mistakes and behavior under one like
lump problem right but at people the
over
response showed that people are able to
differentiate between people's mistakes
and they didn't put me under the same
category as you know a Harvey Weinstein
or they name your your problem and
Alyssa Milano sure I don't know I don't
know what's good I didn't even know she
just yeah she just won't shut up all the
time um but no I feel you though like
well this but yeah it seems to me like
most people can differentiate and it's
like so why does it seem why do you were
you shocked at like your employer's have
to go with you know a couple of blogs
that you know that nobody maybe even
reads writing something I think barstool
understands that by being a writer there
I have I have privilege and an
obligation to be more careful there are
so many eyeballs it's such a big
platform and such a gift to be able to
write there that you have to be careful
and you have to be better than I was you
know I hate to say it but like that that
blog I wrote was not even I wasn't it
was a lazy blog in every sense of the
world I see what you're saying it wasn't
like something that I would have hung my
hat on or been like this is good work it
was just something I wrote to like show
that I had come to work that day I say
and and that's just unacceptable
especially with that subject so I
totally understand
Dave Portland's decision to say you know
I that I had abused the platform they
gave me I made the company look bad and
for it
you know by by losing my job so I get it
and it's it's fair to me mmm wow man
it's a lot of ownership by you man I
think it's really um it's really
remarkable even here just hearing you
say that like you know to recognize your
own part in things
no matter what the outcome even if you
even if inside of yourself somewhere you
felt the outcome was just or wasn't just
like just to recognize your own part in
it and I mean it probably gives you a
little bit more of a place of power than
or comfort than a place of just sitting
there like with your head between your
your hands yeah cuz you're like one of
the most talented guys man I mean I
think you're so talented so charismatic
and I think Dave even said that uh
you know watched his Instagram video do
you think that if if barstool wasn't
owned by like a larger company that they
that that this still would have been the
case or do you think that you know do
you think that that plays like a bigger
role just not just into like overall
like decisions that have to be made like
oh we're part of a bigger group now so
this is some you know there are other
voices that influence right it's a good
question and one that a lot of people
have asked me and honestly personally
it's a lot healthier for me to just not
question it very much and to just know
that I screwed up and that it's on me
and that I could play the what if game
in so many different ways right if what
if she had turned up alive and was fine
like would I be in trouble into the same
degree right um and what if you know
they hadn't
if barstool hadn't been the
controversial company that it is right
would I have been dealt with the same
way I can ask so many questions but the
bottom line is I did something really
stupid and in a professional setting
when you work somewhere there has to be
consequences and if this is the
punishment that they decided fit the
crime I I stand by that I stand with
them and I I'm only grateful for what
they provided me for all those years and
I can live with it you know yeah well
man you're a champ man no it's just it's
such a you know it's such a on word like
moving forward positive way to to
interpret
to interpret it all no matter no matter
what it's like just accepting finding
your role in it look I've I kind of was
I could have been you know I have a
platform I was just trying to do
something that worked that day I didn't
do as much of the background stuff as I
could have just knowing that you didn't
really rise to the occasion as much as
you probably should have and so
therefore even though it got out of
control after that that there were some
consequences yeah exactly and I think
look you know we're comedians if anyone
out there actually thinks that I was
writing a piece in in an effort to
disgrace or mock no one does who had
lost her life like that person that's
crazy yeah course not I'm no one is I
don't know anyone that you know and you
know I think when you have that many
eyeballs as I said you have to be a
little bit more careful and a little bit
more professional yeah I just dropped
the ball and that's what it was yeah
yeah it's tough too cuz also you're in
an environment where like you know
barstool there's this whole vibe there
where it's not kind of professional and
it's not organized but at the same time
it is very much so it's like yeah so
it's I mean this is such a tough space
almost to really live in a little bit um
to embody the brand but at the same time
to recognize a you know a responsibility
in a place that almost thrives on
pushing kind of irresponsibility in some
ways yeah I think exactly and I think
you know I had a lot the one thing that
was so amazing about working a parcel is
that they give you so much Liberty to
create your own work to come up with
your own ideas to act on your own
comedic impulses and you know you don't
always get it right like sometimes
you're not funny sometimes you're just
stupid and sometimes you're really
offensive and unfortunately I think all
three were the case working against
that dirty trifecta bruh yeah exactly
the old bowling Turkey oh yeah
trying to speak the ov on language and I
can't oh yeah but you know it was one of
those things where I had I had a their
respect and Trust in that I would put
out my own work and it would not be
problematic
because I had writing for there long
enough that they said okay you're you're
independent you're on your own we we
don't need to hold your hand anymore
yeah
cruise control Cana yeah exactly and
then you know you're just just one
morning you kind of come in and yeah
yeah you don't have you don't have it on
yeah I don't know how else to put it
like I looking back I don't even
understand what I was thinking mm-hmm
ridiculous yeah yeah I guess in
hindsight it seems it's almost like a
bizarre thing to even kind of get into
but but I think that's you know like
that those the websites and stuff like I
mean you know here in Los Angeles you
hear all you know so many women like you
know screaming about feminism and you
know and just a lot of violent feminists
out here as well but then you see these
literally on on every other billboard
you'll see a sugar baby or a sugar daddy
website which is you know I don't think
those websites a lot of men that I know
they're on those are you know are sick
man or troubled men who were just using
women for sex and not even giving them
an e any money or any it just seems like
a scary place and I guess you know that
element of the story unfortunately it
was something that I did include but I I
was reading off of all the websites and
every story was talking about her
involvement on those oh yeah her daddy
thinks and it was like you know ABC News
like I didn't I didn't bring that to
light and I didn't I there was one news
source that said that I are like one
article that said that I was
slut-shaming this club
and that I mean that is so that is such
a ridiculous that's ridiculous dude if
you look at the blog in no way did I
ever say like oh no she she's a bit a
bless her person for having been on
these websites I I think I just included
it cuz maybe they thought that that was
one of the things that might have been
why she was missing ya know a hundred
percent look at and it's a scary place
it's a scary place for interaction
especially when you're you know when the
product a lot of the times is such an
intimate product it's like you know if
you want to meet somebody to buy shoes
you could do that out in the front yard
but if you're meeting somebody to engage
in you know romantic engagement see
whether it's a massage or just sitting
there watching television together or
even sexual endeavors it's gonna be
behind closed doors so is a lot it's
it's very very spooky and sometimes I
worry that a lot of the you know some of
the like a lot of young women they you
know they say you know they hear all
this body empowerment you you know you
control your own sex and this and that
and which is true no doubt but the fact
that some of these young ladies could be
misinterpreting that and thinking you
know okay well you know I don't need to
be giving my body away for for you know
for free or anything and then they maybe
misconstruing it and and ending up on a
lot of these sites you know I think we
just don't know some of the byproduct of
you know some of these big movements
sometimes yeah you know it's I don't
know much about the world of the the
seeking arrangement I think was the
website yeah that whole thing always
seemed I don't know I don't know it's
like hopefully you hope it's a mutually
but I guess safe agreements yes risky
how can you cook how can you control
that yeah that's risky man it's just and
look yeah it's very sad I mean obviously
no one thinks that it's entertaining or
funny you know what happened to this
young lady and and it's very sad but you
know yeah it's like
I mean you know you just wonder like if
if like you know some higher presence is
using her to help you know a lot of you
know maybe tens of thousands of other
girls you know stay safe you know very
true very well said yeah absolutely um
well you're one of the funniest and most
talented guys that I know man everybody
I met at the bar stole me importantly
knows how to hire that is for damn sure
thanks brother yeah it's it's good to
talk to you man love love what you're
doing you're one of the most unique
people I've ever met and looking forward
to to seeing you again soon my man yeah
same here man I'll be in touch soon man
you got to come into a some weekend with
me or something
hell yeah absolutely appreciate it
all right thanks Francis have a good one
man you talk peace bro and that's him
right there Francis from barstool you
know really I mean an eloquent smart guy
and man he'd probably bout six foot five
but I think about 40% of it is heart the
guy's got a big heart and you know just
to be right there learn from his mistake
or you know learn from even what other
people say is your mistake fine I'm
gonna learn from it no matter what
instead of fighting the tide you know
instead of being just a salmon that
don't really have a plan but he keeps
swimming against the current he just
said I'm gonna ride it you know I'm
never sit here and stay in the current
and just think um let's take one more
call here we go hey Austin thank you for
calling him brother homeward always
wanted your opinion so me and my ex-wife
went through a pretty nasty divorce in
2017 it was just like nasty between us
we have two little kids
what kind of went on and dated other
people I got my own place now I'm
recently single
she's been coming around a little bit
more than she used to
and we've been doing some fun stuff with
the kids but she's been like staying the
night and I really know what to do
because she's dating this other guy like
I said kind of feel like it's different
cause we used to be married and we got
kids and stuff and I'm kind of hoping
that we rekindle her be used to happen
like you know get my family back
together but with her dating this other
guy maybe I should
cutter offs or I don't know what to do
man looking for your opinion thanks for
everything you do
I love the podcast game game game bruh
thank you for calling in wow this is a
real serious thing you know you're so
poignant in the way that you really
expressed it and just shared exactly
what was going on you know you have an
ex and you have children together you
guys are spending time together again
there's times when she'll stay over
spend time around that seems a little
bit you know extra dishes maybe if
that's a word and and but she also was
dating someone and so what do you do I
mean first of all man it's good to be
taking this moment to think before you
take this a wild action because you do
something while you might you know you
you could spoil things because you have
a couple good things going to me for one
you have the time you guys are able to
spend with the kids together and I think
that that is probably really priceless
so I think it no matter what you do
probably take it through that filter
first but since I don't have any
children and I haven't been in this
situation I think I'm gonna see if our
listeners have any suggestions for you
you know and you guys heard the call you
guys heard his you know what he's in
what you know what should he do she's
still dating this other guy now I'll say
this man in my experience with
rekindling things with an ex you always
have a stronger hold if you had a real
place in that person's heart and you
probably do if you've had it if you've
had a couple children that you always
have a stronger hold a foothold in there
then you ever realize maybe and the
thing is if you do go if you do end up
back together or really tightening
things up you want it to be really
perfect because you can't you it has to
be you know you you're not gonna if it's
going to happen it needs to be a
different experience than the one that
took you guys apart so so I think yeah
being patient obviously is key because
you can't make any you could you know
it's easy for you to make a wrong move
here it feels like so I think obviously
being loving
first and foremost especially with the
kids and then let's see what some other
people say man let's see what some of
our listeners suggest for you the number
is nine eighty five six six four nine
five zero three let me get your name one
more time Austin in Utah if you have a
suggestion for Austin you can hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three we had some more
some patriotic questions I'm gonna get
to those next time also have you know we
got some new Billy conforto charts up on
the website Theo von comm slash store
and thank you everyone who came out last
week
to Tulsa to Cain's Ballroom to the Tower
Theater over there in Oklahoma City to
San Antonio and to Austin and what an
experience you know I'm just I'm getting
to live my dream and and we did it man
we did it we did it and I really feel
that way and thank you so much you know
I don't know sometimes we just have a
special group now I don't know what
we're gonna do what we're gonna damn
well do it but yeah happy Independence
Day to you you know god bless all the
men and women who are currently serving
their serving our country and you have
served thank you
you know much braver than me there's not
a moment at the airport when I see a um
you know some someone in military jacket
saying goodbye to their loved one or
something you know and see that moment
or see them kissing out front or you
know see the couple already you know the
mom or dad you know hugging their kids
or saying bye and man it just goes real
deep in me and do it I'll tell you this
one of my new uplifters if I'm not
feeling well I'll watch those military
surprise videos on the Internet yeah
dude I didn't know I had so many tears
in my body I mean I'm just him I will
just start leaking out of my eyes I mean
just like a dam like a fire hydrant in
the summer in Brooklyn man I just
started I just can't handle it
and I just really lose myself man when I
see it and sometimes it's the you know
it's the kid at school and they opened
the door and it's the football player
and he runs through the paper and his
dad's right there and it just you know I
don't know there's just something about
those videos that encapsulates human
connection for me oh man
but thank you very much happy 4th of
July
happy Independence Day to you and yeah
what it means to be independent man
sometimes I feel so independent though
that I just I feel like you know I got
to fight it in some ways I got to just
you know uh because I want to be I'm
gonna have other people in my life I
don't want to be alone you know and I'm
not alone but I don't you know it's like
there's that thing in me that wants me
to stay alone sometimes it's that dark
art I wants to just keep me behind the
curtain so I don't know I'm all over the
place man my neck is killing me I got to
go get some some type of relief but uh
you guys be good to yourselves man you
know you deserve it and I love you if
nobody told you that today I'll tell you
right now straight up
Point Blank son or daughter I love you
and uh and I hope you have a happy 4th
of July
if you're not doing something reach out
to somebody you know is doing something
asking if you can bring something by do
something make a little plan Eve you
know if you don't have plans make a plan
somebody didn't reach out to you don't
think about it like that go reach out to
somebody else and ask them to go do
something and then they might say oh
well you know I I'm already doing this
why don't you come with me you know uh
sometimes one of the main things that's
keeping us alone is ourselves sadly you
know it's so hard sometimes to reach out
to somebody else it really is and it
crazy sometimes it's so hard to reach
out to somebody and say look you know I
don't really want to be alone you know
but then if somebody hears that they can
relate to that so much man being alive
it is a fascinating journey and
and that's it I don't know why I keep
rambling but but yeah man I'm just so
grateful man what a just an amazing
weekend to go to just really some
beautiful places in America
you know just snail it along you know
that just Snelling along go celebrate
[Music]
celebrate live
celebrate ms
[Music]
while we all die
celebrate dog day
Oh
[Music]
sighs
let's have some fun while we all die
[Music]
you